[Music]
we're down to two teams so for double
points what is the name of the purple
Teletubby since Yugi
you're both correct he always carried
red purse max is very competitive as
mine it's one of the reasons I fell in
love with him
oh this is easy he was an incredible
Eric man another one mark ruffalo other
one lou ferrigno primal fear richard
gere never played the incredible hi
Jesus Christ
Norton guys what do you say we do this
at my house next week this will be a
game night to remember
oh boy tonight we're taking game night
up a notch we don't need a board and we
do not need pieces we won't need an
extra rudeness either someone in this
room is going to be taken oh it's a
murder mystery party fine whoever finds
the victim wins the grand prize the keys
to the Stingray
Josefa keys no Ryan the whole car oh
yeah this is why don't we see the best a
lot tonight
bye baby Amy those matches about to burn
this door down
you're gonna light a fire in a
windowless room that we're trapped in I
got to make my idea sounds stupid you're
not gonna know what's real what's fake
is this gun real Oh oh my god I've
always enjoyed that I'm not real good
friends stuff and we don't appreciate
what we have until it's gone oh because
your wife left you
[Music]
so much worse okay I've one idea it's so
crazy it just might work
you're gonna crush the car into the
plane like Liam Neeson taken three he
did that and taking three huh
you missed it thanks baby
this is instructions on how to remove a
bullet didn't so I got you this lovely
shark good idea hue to pivot what is
helpful and Country Living
oh that's for later corn chowder recipe
looks really good huh
you love chatter do let's you
[Music]